I'm Ariel tolki and I'm a makeup artist
in local 798 and I work on film and
television there's a lot of actors that
have a hard time crying when prompted
some actors are really good at crying on
cue and some actors need a little bit of
help
so we employ one method two methods
sometimes a lot of different methods to
sort of get them to where they need to
be visually for the scene I am ready to
drive
[Music]
I feel like sometimes in a lot of comedy
you know to be like one tear getting you
going and running in with an eye drop
you know you're just standing right off
a camera and you can just run into that
one drop and you know get it ready for
they they roll like you know yes of
course there's a benefit to that in
addition to actors natural tears we
might use like a Vaseline based product
in order for it to look like there's
been a lot of crying sometimes even if
an actor's getting there sometimes this
helps them get there faster any artists
will always have some sort of Vaseline
based product in their kit whether it's
you know like aquaphor or some sort of
clear gloss
then there's the - menthol applications
one is the Krylon - your stick which
looks like a lipstick with menthol in it
and that's applied under the eyes and
then also it's like a little bit kind of
shiny so you sort of does do that a
little bit of a double duty that a
vaseline based product will with either
of the menthol products and do not get
that directly in somebody's eyes
nobody's gonna like lose an eye over it
but it's definitely very uncomfortable
so using the tear stick you want to be
careful when applying it that you get it
close but not in the eye and that your
actor doesn't rub their eye okay yep yes
yeah yeah try to keep your eyes open
and then there's the blower which you
literally blow when menthol air into
somebody's eyes oh yeah now there it is
which totally irritates your eyes and
the benefit to using the menthol
versions is that because it's literally
irritating the eye that I will get read
so if you've ever seen yourself after
you've cried your eyes are puffy and red
because you're sort of like irritating
and rubbing your eye and so that menthol
application does that to your actor you
always want to blow into your hand first
and make sure that the cotton is there
and it didn't move I've heard horror
stories where I know you know somebody
borrowed in them the blue menthal
crystals in somebody's eye and then you
nobody wants that that would just be you
know you've completely ruined the scene
for everybody
my eyesight so bad and that makes me
really sad
Oh bad actor